سترتكب خطا جسيما اذا سلمت طفلك هاتفا
ذكيا او جهازا لوحيا في سنوات عمره الاولى
فاذا كنت تفعل ذلك الان توقف فورا لكن
لماذا دراسه جديده كشفت انه كلما تم اعطاء
الطفل هاتفا ذكيا مبكرا زادت فرص تعرضه
لمشاكل الصحه العقليه كشاب بالغ لنوضح ذلك
اكثر الدراسه التي اجرتها مؤسسه امريكيه
في اكثر من اربعين دوله تقول ان الشباب
الذين امتلكوا هواتف ذكيه في وقت مبكر من
الطفوله يعانون مشاكل عقليه عده ابرزها
خطوره البحث عن المزيد من الافكار التي
تتعلق بانهاء الحياه ومشاعر العداء تجاه
الاخرين والشعور بالانفصال عن الواقع اعني
هنا انهم يشعرون باحساس اضعف بالذات
الاجتماعيه اي كيف ينظر المرء الى نفسه
والى الاخرين في النهايه نتائج الدراسه
واضحه للاباء من الافضل تاخير اعطاء الطفل
الهاتف الذكي قدر الامكان